[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم ومرحبا مشاهدينا الكرام
الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات في
تونس اطراف سياسيه معارضه
منهجه لتشويه الانتخابيه في البلاد
وترذيلها بهدف التاثير على المشاركه في
هذه الانتخابات
من تونس العاصمه السيد حاتم اليحياوي
السياسيه والمتحدث الرسمي 25 جويليا سيد
حاتم يحيى اهلا بكم ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك
على تلبيه هذه الدعوه اهلا بك مرحبا
دائما
في عبر الاقمار الصناعيه من تونس العاصمه
السيد خليل الزاويه رئيس حزب تكاتل
الديمقراطيه من اجل العمل والحريات وزير
الشؤون الاجتماعيه
للزاويه اهلا بك ومرحبا شكرا جزيلا لك
ايضا على تربيه هذه الدعوه
مرحبا وشكرا على الاستضافه مرحبا مرحبا
بكم كل ترحيب مع بدايه وصفت صراحه
بالهزليه لبعض المرشحين كما نقرا ذلك حتى
على صحيفه عميده صحيفه الصباح التونسيه
الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات تقول
انما مقاطع الفيديو والصور التي يتم
تداولها في صفحات التواصل الاجتماعي
والمواقع الالكترونيه لا تتعلقوا في
اغلبها بمترشحين لانتخابات اعضاء مجلس
النواب وكانه ثم من يرغب في تشويه العمليه
وهنا اسال هل تم فعلا حمله منهجه تقف
وراءها احزاب وشخصيات سياسيه معارضه كما
تقول هيئه الانتخابات لضرب المسار
الانتخابيه يطرح لك سؤال اولا سيد حاتم
يحيى ولمدير الشؤون السياسيه والمتحدث
الرسمي باسم حضرتك 25 جويريه مرحبا من
جديد
مرحبا
كيفك مرحبا بسيد المشاهدين بالنسبه
للتعمليه تبديل الحمل الانتخابيه هي طريقه
يعني تعتمدها الاحزاب المعارضه لهذه
الحمله الانتخابيه و لهذه العمليه
الانتخابيه باسرها
لذلك تسعه من خلال هذه العمله اللي هي
الترديد يعني كافه المترشحين الى الحكم
المستواهم وذلك من خلال نشر بعض
الفيديوهات وبعض الصور يعني هذه اذا فيش
لمترشحين وهميين وهم غير موجودين بالقيمه
المترشحين ونسبه امور يعني لهؤلاء على
اساس انا مترشحون في الحمله ولكن هذا يضر
بالصوره العمليه الديمقراطيه اساسها هذا
ان همم يعني انه توجه نحو احداث نوع من
العزوف لا تنتخبين التونسيه
اقلت ما اثبات انها لا تعود لي همم
مترشحين البعض همم الاخر من الملصقات التي
تم تداولها همم صحيح سيد خليل الزاويه
رئيس حزب تكتل الديمقراطي من اجل العمل
والحريات وزير الشؤون الاجتماعيه الاسبق
هل فعلا همم تعمل اطراف سياسيه لهم في
تونس بشكل
عموم الناخبين من العمل الانتخابيه على
ترديد هذه العمليه والحيلوله دون نجاح هذا
الاستحقاق التشريعي كما اا تشير الى ذلك
هيئه الانتخابات
واطراف من بينها حركه 25 فيديو
يعني هو من حق الاحزاب السياسيه ان تدعوا
الى مقاطعه الانتخابات وهذه حريتها وهذا
هو قرارها المستقل يعني اليوم ثم اغلبيه
الاحزاب السياسيه تدعو الى مقاطعه
الانتخابات وتعتبر ان هذه الانتخابات ليست
بعمليه السياسيه وليست بانتخابات وانما هي
تركيز لمنظومه الرئيس قيس عيد المنظومه
التي ترفضها جل الاحزاب السياسيه
هنالك عديد المترشحين
نشره مقاطع فيديو
ليست في المستوى وهذا تم تداوله من بعض
المواقع الاخرى لابراز انه جل المترشحين
يعني
الزاويه
فقط حتى نوضح لمشاهدين ليست في المستوى
يعني يعني يعني
معناها عندما عندما
شكلا مضمونا تقصد او كيف حصانا
الشكل لانه مضمون
الشكل يعني عندما يكون مترشح ايام تطيح
حصانا وكانه في غزوه او اا مترشح يكون
خارج سيارته
حقيقيه مترشحين حقيقيين وليس وهميين همم
يطل من سياره سيارته من من اعلى سياره
ويكون بخطاب على شكل بن علي فهذا معناها
همم مستواه متدني على مستوى همم شكل على
بص هو المضمون كل ال- ال- الملاحدين وكل
لحظه ان جل المتدخلين في وسائل الاعلام
همم المسموعه والمرئيه مستويه تدخلاتهم
ضعيف جدا وليس لهم برامج حقيقيه لانه
القانون الانتخابي اقسى اقسى مشاركه
الاحزاب وبالت لمضمون الخطاب
ملحوظ عديدا لمترشحين الذين تدخلوا في
الاذاعات كان مضمونهم ضعيف جدا ولا يعرفون
ماذا يريدون من المشاركه في الانتخابات
فقد كما قال احدهم انا لا ادعي ان النساء
احسن وضعكم فحسنوا وضعي بانتخابي لكي
يتحصل على اجر مجدي طيب اذا المستوى
المتدن والبعض من همم
المنتقدين الذي عين للرئيس قيس سيد حتى
تعود ليس سيد حاتم لحياوي يقولون انه هذا
ما يرغب به الرئيس فعلا وثم تشقق اخر من
المتابعين لم يتوالى عن اتهام هيئه
الانتخابات بانها اصبحت تمارس الوصايا
الكليه على مسار مشكوك فيه اصلا واتحاد
الشغل نفسه السيد حاتم الاحياء ومدير شؤون
السياسيه والمتحدث الرسمي باسم حضرتك 25
جوليا اتحاد الشغل نفسه يقول ان انتخابات
ديسمبر لن يكون لها لا
ولا طعم معتبرا انها نتيجه لدستور يفتقر
الى الاجماع الوطني والتشاركيه ضيف من
تونس العاصمه يقول من حقنا ان نقاطع همم
هذا همم هذا المسار انتخابي
بالنسبه لاتحاد التونسي للشغل هو ليس
بالحزب السياسي بالنسبه له همم اتفهم هذا
رايه ويعبر عنه عنه هو حر في التعبير عن
رايه لكنه لا يستطيع ان اخرجته في العمليه
السياسيه باعتبار ان الخيرات في العمليه
السياسيه يجيبه ثلاث توفير المترشحين مثل
مع قام بذلك حريق 25 يوليا كذلك بالنسبه
لنوعيه المترشحين هذه حاجه تحسب لنا
حافظنا على ان يكون مرشحين لما الاساتذه
الجامعيه الموجودين الدكاتره اطباء كذلك
موظفين سامي من الدوله كذلك المديرين يعني
بالقطاع الخاص وغيره بالنسبه لنا لان
البرنامج الوطني هو موجود يعني والحزب بقى
عنه البرامج الموجوده على المستوى الجهوي
يحكم فيها هذا القانون الذي قام باعتباره
على دوائر انتخابيه ضيقه على الافراد اذا
يغلب الطابع الجهوي المحلي لكن بالنسبه
للبرلمان هو سيكون في اطار برنامج كامل
برنامج وطني باعتبار الفصل 77 من الدستور
يمنح البرلمان يعني الحق في همم انه يكو
يضع يعني المخططات تنمويه هذا يجعل من
الرايه انها يجب ان تكون يعني همم
وعامه على كامل الوضع داخل الوطن التونسي
مرشحين بشرطه شهادات عليا او همم ولكن
المهم ان تكون هناك على الاقل نتبعه الحال
همم ثقافه حتى سياسيه لان هذا هذا المهم
ورؤيه على القلب بالنسبه للبلاد واجب ان
تكون ايضا هذه الانتخابات من خلال مرشحين
تمثل الجميع وجميع في فئات همم الوطن هنا
اود ان احيل سؤال لضيفي السيد خليل
الزاويه رئيس حزب التكت ولا الديمقرا من
اجل العمل والحريات ما تعليقك ان سيدخل
للزاويه على تغير لهجه خطاب اتحاد الشغل
هل هي ظرفيه ككل شهر ديسمبر من كل عام كما
قال لنا قبل ايام السيد محمد المسيلين يوم
القيادي في حركه الشعب هل هي احتجاجا على
مصالح ضيقه همم تخص الاتحاد بعد اخراج
الرئيس للاتحاد الشغل من المعادله كما
يقول منتقد دول الاتحاد ام انها فعلا من
وجهه نظرك نابعه من احساس بخطر داهم بخطر
يداهم البلاد
اعتقد انه تغيير موقف الاتحاد متادمه
المسالتين مثلا الاولى الاساسيه هو
اقرار الاتحاد وجميع
المتدخلين اغلب المتدخلين السياسيين
والتونسيين والمواطنين انه هذه الحكومه
فشلت في مواجهه الوضع الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي للبلاد التونسيه والتونسيين
واننا نعيش وضعيه ماليه صعبه والحكومه
ليست لها همم مشروع للخروج من الازمه ولها
مفوضات مع صندوق النقد الدولي في كان في
السريه وفي عدم الشفافيه واا نعيش على همم
الخوف من صدور همم
الرائد الرسمي او البلاغات اللي همم تخص
زيادات في همم سعر البنزين وفي تضخم همم
حاليا يعني همم قارب الرقمين يعني 10% هذه
الجانب الاول والاتحاد يدافع على منخرتي
وعلى الاجراء بصفه عامه
ويعتبر ان العلاقه مع الحكومه متازمه
حاليا ثاني حاجه يرى انها الاتحاد ان
المسار السياسي في ظل هذه الازمه
الاقتصاديه المسار السياسي يؤزم الوضع في
البلاد ويجعل انه الاحساس وان البلاد في
همم ضائقه وفي زنقه حاده كما يقال
وانه ال- ال- المشروع السياسي لرئيس قيس
سعيد سوف يعمق الازمه السياسيه
ويجعل الازمه الاقتصاديه اصعب فبالتالي
موقفه من الانتخابات وهو يلاحظ انه
العزوف المتوقع الكبير للا التونسي على
الذهاب الى صندوق
الاقتراعظ انه ليست هنالك حملا انتخابيه
وليست هنالك برامج لاحزاب السياسيه
وليست هنالك مترشحين في مجملهم يعني
يرفعون بالنقاش السياسي والحوار السياسي
الى مستويات تحديات التي تعيشها البلاد
حاليا فمقبل الاتحاد ليس ظرفي وانما هو اا
تقييمه للوضع بكل موضوعيه وان البلاد ذاهب
الى ما ازن سياسي زياده على صعوبات
الماليه التي تعيشها الدوله الاسلاميه
التي تعيشها البلاد حتى تعود لي السيد
حاتم يحيى سياسيه ومتحدث الرسمي باسم
حضرتك 25 جويليا من كان دائما سيد حاتم
اليحيوي ومن كان حتى معارضا لمصر كان
ينتظر في لحظه ما من الرئيس ان يقوم بلم
شم الجميع ان ينفتح على الجميع ان يفتح
حوار وطنيا شاملا يجمع الجميع ولكنه تفرد
بالسلطه والقرار يقول معارضوه وكما ياسف
حتى بعض من مسانده في
البدايه كانت اتحاد الشغل نفسه الذي باتي
يقول هذا اليوم ان 25 جوليا الحركه عن
مساره والديكم حتى انتم في حركه 25 فيلا
بعض التحفظات وبعض الدعوات
للتغيير
وبعض المراجعات كيف ترقب كل همم ذلك
هذا صحيح يوجد بعث التعثر لكن بالنسبه
للعمل والاداء يعني السلطه التنفيذيه هو
الادب بالنسبه للتعثر ياتي في اداء
الحكومه لانه بالنسبه لنا ما همم لاحظنا
انه هي حكومه التصريف اعمال اكثر منه يعني
حكومه لدي برنامج
التركيز كل التركيز اللي يحذف فيه من جانب
رئيس الدوله في خصوص المشروع السياسي هو
غيركم لهذا المشروع السياسي وهو بيسدد
يعني الانتهاء منه لانه الدخول للخروج من
الاستثناء والدخول للحاله الدائمه القارئ
يعني مؤسسه الدوله بعد يقع تركيزها يجب
الاسرع فيه لذلك نشجع كيف تونسيين على
المشاركه في هذه الانتخابات والتصويت لكي
يقع تاسيس يعني المؤسسات الدوله
والعبور الى مرحله ما بعد السياسي للدخول
في بناء الدوله صحيح بالنسبه لنا الازمه
العالميه على الق اللي لها على تونس صحيح
لكلاب منه 9.8 زي ال- بالنسبه للارقام زاد
هذه ما لناش في نقعدون احنا نقارنه فيها
الدول الاخرى تعدت حتى 10 فاصلتين واكثر
من ذلك قريبا منه في اوروبا لكن بالنسبه
لي تونس التوازنات الماليه هي اللي ت-
تحكم يعني هذه الازمه الحمد لله التصنيف
تونس بدا يتحاسل من تصنيف الذات الدولي
لذلك نحن نسعى بالنسبه الى الحركه 25
جميلا ادي لا تاسيس برلمان يعني يكون لبنى
في بناء ال- همم الاغتصاب وفي الخروج من
هذه الازمه لانه لا يكون الا بالعمل ولا
شيء غير العمل ولا على التونسيين التحرك
لان السقوط
وعزوف كما يسعى الى تصويره يعني معارضه
قيس سعيد لن ينفع شيء بالعكس يزيده من
تازيم الوضع الخروج من هذه
الاقتصاديه فقط هي اقتصاديه لانه الازمه
السياسيه نحن بسدد الخروج منها بالنسبه
لما يلام على رئيس الجمهوريه هو فقط يعني
في حدود الاتصال هي بازمه اتصاليه يمكن
التعثر بالنسبه للحكومه لكن البرنامج واضح
بالنسبه لحرق 25
سيد حاتم يحيىوي
الحوار هناك الاطراف
ماذا يقول كلها ذهبت الى جامعه الخلاص
واعتبرت ان العمليه هي عمليه انقلابيه لكن
هي بالنسبه
للطرف ان عملي دستوريه صحيح هي المرحله
التاسيس التاسيس كما يعلم الجميع يستحق
الخروج من فتره الى اخرى اي مرحله
انتخاليه هذا الانتقال يجب الخروج منه
والدخول في مرحله المؤسسات دائما
الذي يعول عليه او كان حتى يعول عليه
كثيرون من اجل الوصول الى توافق ومن اجل
اخراج البلاد من ازمتها غياب هذا الحوار
هل يطرح بالنسبه لكم اي اشكال ام انه همم
اشكال همم يذكر والمصان
همم يتواصل ولا ضيف ان يكون هناك معرضون
وننا نتحاور معهم
باختصار بالنسبه للحوار هذا همم بكل
الاختصار الحوار هو مطلوب بين الجميع لكن
على اساس اتمام مسار 5 25 جميليليه اي
اهتمام المرحله الانتقاليه وليس الدعوه
الى ادخال البلاد في فوضه والرجوع بها الى
النقطه صفر بطبيعه حتى اطراف من التيتو
نادر اليوم التظاهر وتعرض حتى همم
الاجراءات رئيس قيس سعيد باتت مقتنعه بانه
لا عوده الى الوراء وان النخبه سياسيه
بشكل عام همم ربما لم تقم بما كان يجب ان
تقوم به اخذ ثلاثه شعب في مرحله انه لكنها
ما زالت تسر على معرضتها لهذا المسار
بشكلها الحالي وتصر ايضا على التظاهر عليك
السؤال في تخليل الزاويه لك ان تحقق ايضا
على مذهب اليه ضيفه
الديمقرا من اجل العمل والحريات رغم جهدها
رغم المحاولاتها المستنيته للحشد والتعبئه
همم المعارضه
كمراقبين ما زالت غير فعاله ما زالت
تنخرها الاقتصاد الانقساماتا كانت
المصلحيه او الايديولوجيه هنا اطرح السؤال
هل تتفق مع هذا الطرح وهل فشلت فعلا
المعارضه همم في همم مهمتها في هذه
المرحله
يعني بطبيعه الحال همم قرارات
رئيس قيس سعيد في 25 جبيل 21 همم لقد دعم
كبير وواسع من الشعب التونسي
بطبيعه الحال همم ضروري
الزمن وممارسه السلطه همم اثبت له
التونسيين ان هذا التوجه بشعب باطروحات
والشعبويه وبختام همم غير متناسق
وبقراراته همم السيئه القرارات السياسيه
والاقتصاديه همم اقناعتها اليوم همم
اطياف كبيره من الشعب التونسي يتذكر اللي
حتى في عمليه الاستفتاء المشاركه لم تصل
الى حدود 30% هذه حسب الارقام الرسميه
يعني والمرتقب انه الانتخابات التشريعيه
سوف تشهد عزوف كبير مع العلم ان هنالك
دوائر ليست لهم فيهم مرشحين مثل دائره في
فرنسا
والدائره الرئيسيه في قلب العاصمه تونس
هنالك مرشح وحيد يعني ليست بالانتخابات
ليست فيها التنازع عن انتخابي او سباق من
اجل كسب اصوات المواطنين فبالتالي همم
اليوم
المواطنين اصبحوا يقتنعون يوم بعد يوم
بازدياد
بان اطروحات المعارضه هي اطروحات صادقه
وان الزمن اثبت ان سياسه قيس سعيد هي
السياسه فاشله سواء كانت على المستوى
الاغتصاب بالاساس ولا على المستوى السياسي
واصبحت همم
الخروج الاعلامي
للسلطه حاليا في بعض الاحيان مصدر
جبهه الخلاصه الوطنيه
المعارضه السبت المقبل ضد مشروع الرئيس
وضد مساره الذي تعثر وفق كثيرين الكلمه
الفيصل من وجهه نظرك اولا تقيمك همم
فاعليه هذه المعارضه والكلمه الفيصل هل
ستكون للشارع ام ستكون لي صناديق الاقتراع
ونسبه المشاركه خاصه وان ضيفي يعتبر ان
هذه النسبه ستكون ضعيفه وانه سيكون هناك
عزوف عن هذه الانتخابات
بالنسبه للعزوف الكماه يزعم يعني
المعارضون هو لا يوجد هنا العضو في الذكر
كل الانتخابات 2019 النسبه قديش كانت هي
نفس النسبه بالنسبه
اكثر منها نقوله
يعني تسجيل الالي عمليه التسجيل الالي
يمكن تسببت في ذلك لكن بالنسبه للعزوف هو
غير موجود العمليه الانتخابيه هي بالاساس
في المشاركه عن طريق التصويت والاقتراع
بالنسبه للجبهه الخلاص في الشارع هي
معزوله وشوفنا جميع تحركاتها اللي ما
عندها حتى يعني همم حالنا شعبيه حتى ادنى
بالعكس انه دخل تونس اين محلات فهي تكون
مطروده ويمكن حتى تتعرضه للهارسل في بعض
الاحيان من تعرف الشعب لانه لفظ هذه
النخبه السياسيه بالنسبه له وتاكد انها
غير مجديه الى 10 سنوات جربها فتاكد له
فشلها بالنسبه لشعب تونسي الحل هو في
صناديق الاغتراع الحل في وضع البرلمان وضع
هذه المؤسسات الدائمه وبتبيعه الحال هو من
حقه انه يعني يحاور ويتبدل بتاريخ مؤس
الدوله عن طريق كذلك هو التحوير يا قصي
يكونوا سياسيا اقتصاديا تدخل للزاويه كنت
قد بدات مع سيد حاتم يحيى ولكن يختم معك
في 20 ثانيه لو سمحتوا عقب على مذهب اليه
ونختم معك هذه الحلقه باختصار
يعني اليوم تونس تعيش في ازمه اقتصاديه
همم جزء منها همم مستورد من الازمه
العالميه ولكن هنالك عوامل همم تونسيه
تونسيه وسياسه السلطه التنفيذيه برئاسه
قيس سعيد سوف تدفع البلاد نحو ازمه
اجتماعيه همم هذه الازمه سوف تكون مضاعفه
بهذا هذه الازمه السياسيه منذ الانقلاب
على الدستور ومن محاوله ترسيخ النداء
القاعدي سوف لن يؤدي الى همم ايجاد مؤسسات
الدوله دائما وممثله للشعب التونسي وهم
سيدفع المواطنين للانتفاض ضد النظام
القائم حاليا شكرا على تربيه دعوتنا في
هذه الحلقه سيد حاتم يحيى ولمدير تونسيا
ومتحدث الرسمي باسم حضرتك 25 كل شكرا
جزيلا لك على تربيه الدعوه كل شيء جزيلا
لك ايضا على تربيه الدعوه للزاويه همم
رئيس حزب التكتل الديمقراطي من اجل العمل
والحريات وزير الشؤون الاجتماعيه الاسباب
كنتم معنا في فقره وجها لوجه